hello welcome to this video playing
mandora Goro yes funky plus grand master
get Sheila from Thailand currently
residing in Thailand for a couple of
years we get the same opening come on
yet what's the deal here and let's go
yeah I always had a soft spot for this
opening I can well it's it's super solid
really is and we we had a discussion
once about this ending yeah to be sure
six where I thought that this should be
just dead equal and he thought white is
better let's see what happens I'm not
super happy about this because he is
simply the better end game player of us
too but we'll see we'll see and I to
judge ig3 to age five is said already on
the cards I one day a 5 80's night
deform and Bishop coming down I don't
know let's play quickly not worry too
much yeah i was thinking bishop there
would be able to be also quite
interesting so here is he going c4 no
maybe Bishop to d7 is clearly a clean
ian option so let's prevent that if you
go see for i have d 4 so this isn't
really threatening and this is also
something i feel that should be very
calm very ok
very hard to imagine how black should
lose this position to take in with the a
pawn may be trying something no it is
just what it is not much happening this
is probably easiest let's prevent the
rook from doing anything yeah what now
so this Bishop d7 and ce4 I don't really
think is a either threat maybe actually
had Roxy 3m okay
okay so i could have taken
yeah the thing is this is one of the
most the absolute safest openings for
whatever and you you can you have a hard
time winning a game but you can
definitely never lose with white is the
thing yes so can also charger and give
up her give up the depot it's not super
important I wants to go on to the key
arc with the King down yeah I would
definitely like to trade the rook
traderoo p.m. I cancel Matt doesn't work
actually hmm King the six roop to e5
does not work and if he attacks this and
I'm defending this badly I just
recognized I'm defending this badly ok I
have to have to the King has to be on g
cell let's just defend it properly this
is the idea ok
sure
yeah you cannot do much and really it's
not very nice rather than equals back
from them check
time warning counter ticking somehow
let's go look to you for probably it's
not good okie two would be cool to get
in play back I have I don't really mind
so much that the deep one dropped ah now
it's quadruped d7 in store Group B 7
holding yep bit of it suits phone
check now a funny thing is it could it
could still be a draw but it's a it's of
course anything else but fun so I'm
trying to do something here also because
of the time situation okay I think it's
to the troll it's just to complete to
watch sure to play
and they have no time of course
it's not a happy move King g8 within 10
seconds since this is the problem check
now now when i blundered like the bloody
bloody porn down but i would have lost
on time anyways the problem the position
was a dead bro i think pretty much dad
ok bro gauge so ok black for fits on
time now this is just the total draw i
think even this you can white cannot win
this ever I don't think so I just have
to have a little bit of time now it's a
total torture of course but you should
not lose it anymore check cannot cannot
really believe it yeah so I really
drifted into this bad ending with some
moves yeah I mean he a black should not
lose of course but it let's receive it
can happen it can happen it's extremely
one-sided is the problem and what I
probably should have done is like invest
like a couple of seconds like 20 30
seconds to find a better way of
defending this for example the deep part
is entirely useless here and I should
probably try to find a setup that is
easier easier to hold
not entirely sure how exactly
the thing is for example a rook trade is
an immediate draw you cannot go you
don't even need to play this position
because black just stays and draws so I
don't know is if there is a way to get
this in
this is this is a wrong approach I mean
this is clearly wrong it loses lots of
time I should probably put the King here
anyway so how do i how do i how do I
play this the day I think there's just a
couple of that I just needed a little
bit of precision to do this the rook
here for example wait I have to do this
this is this is a good name and this is
this is this is you know the difference
sometimes playing a position in the
Blitz game or playing it in a in a in a
game where you have time if you go if I
play this movie I'm white has absolutely
no chance of doing anything because now
his rook is basically trapped here on f5
and if he plays F form he has no ideas
with the rooks on the fourth-ranked and
it's very difficult to not play a four
years as i said the rook is kind of
trapped and so he probably will go f
form and then i go back and the
difference is pretty big because now the
rook doesn't have this play on the
fourth-ranked that it had in the game
and now i'm drawing this a thing fairly
easily you can do whatever I put the
king here and now he cannot check me he
cannot bring me or force me away from g7
so I'm staying here and just I just I
just stay put and this should be a draw
because it cannot harass my pawns
anymore it's a big difference to the
game and the game I lost a bit of time
with the king then I realized they have
to go back and now there is this rook
f/4g for business which makes it awkward
yeah really awkward yeah it might still
be a drawer whatever but it would have
been a lot easier a lot easier if I
would have played we should be five
chair yeah I'm not I'm not such a
precise and game player just what it is
I mean I can't find the things but I
need a bit of time and it's it's not not
it doesn't come very natural to me and
those things and yeah here in his his
his he is in complete torture mode I
already don't know I still think it
could be a row back so yeah maybe I mean
I played this f5 not sure about this I
wanted to do something because of the
time situation I didn't want to stay put
the whole time and this is frankly
should should help I'd will be 87 hmmm
yeah I know that's tough to say if this
is still holds or not
I'm really not sure I'm really not sure
my natural optimism says it should hold
it but it's not easy to say recorder you
can if you want help by the engine
forget it that that's not helping you at
all here
how did I actually lose justice to see
me okay no time everything we know the
deal yeah okay I actually went back here
because I didn't ok I can do it I can do
this of course that I forgot about that
I didn't want to cooking g8 of course is
the sea having to see I mean the moment
he goes here a check if he goes age six
and just trades f against age is a it's
a media draw I think it's still doable
to be sorry I still think it's the draw
here mhm probably yes I mean it's it's
it's not fun now but I think it's still
it's still holds but we should be fired
was was a lot better that would have
saved me probably have a point and lots
of nerves defending this this position
ok guys thanks for watching